The joe rogan experience.
So,
uh,
what is it like working with the vice guys were fucking loved it.
I love vice man vices there.
I've worked with so many people and vice just let you do your thing and that's
the best part.
And like I just went through a whole week.
I was at Ted,
I'm a ted fellow this year and I went through a whole week of people telling me
what to do,
where to be and it was like being at a fucking Scientology summer camp.
It was horrible.
Yeah.
Tell me what the fuck happened.
They told you that you,
you,
you can't leave.
Yeah.
Like before you go there,
like you need to participate in Ted,
you need to beat them.
Like all right,
cool.
Like I figure like mines are reasonable.
If you have to do something in La,
you can go do something.
In La,
I gave them like four or five days of my time.
Like I was there every single 13 hours.
Like every day they have 13 hours of fucking activities.
They have mapped out for you some days,
like 1516 hours.
Right.
If you go to their after events and I'm like that's way too much fucking human
interaction days.
Explain this.
So you go there and you're going to go and do your own Ted speech,
right?
Yeah.
So you do your own Ted speech.
What does the other stuff they have for you?
They want you to be available for like networking,
cocktail events like attendees want to talk to you,
you need to be available.
And I was like,
look,
I,
I've done a lot.
Like I put people on,
like I put them in touch with ad agency people,
I put them in touch with other people to do business with other artists,
introducing everyone and I thought I was good.
So I went yesterday to go do DVD asa and when I met up Cho,
I met up Assa then I went and now they called me today on the way over here and
they were like,
we're taking your fed Ted Fellowship where I was like,
why are you taking the Ted Fellowship?
Like because you went to la.
I was like,
you're in Long Beach.
I just went to La for the afternoon to do the fucking podcast.
You're fucking crazy.
And they're like,
you took this spot from somebody who would have gone to every talk and been in
everything.
I was like,
Yo,
the other people weren't there for everything.
But you're also just crazy.
Like you're fucking crazy.
Crazy.
They're not paying you.
No,
they don't pay that's incense and go to do it for the love and they want you for
seven days,
12 to 15 hours a day,
and you can't just leave to go do something.
Some work that you have to do.
Yeah.
It's fucked up.
What,
what is it where people fuck up everything.
Even something as amazing as Ted,
because Ted,
I remember the first Ted talk that I ever saw on the Internet a couple of years
ago.
We have a whole ted thread on my message board about great,
uh,
great ted episodes.
Yeah.
Like the one how to be happy is great.
Oh,
there's so many of them all.
But Graham Hancock just gave one in the war and consciousness about Iowasca and,
and his own problems with,
uh,
kicking cannabis.
He had like a crazy weed habit where he's high all day every day for like
decades.
And then electra was,
it was a crutch for them.
It was like a real problem.
Um,
great.
Ted Talk about it though.
There's so much good stuff,
but then you hear shit like this and you're like,
even they suck.
Like even if someone finds a way to fuck up,
even something as amazing as Ted.
Yeah,
the speakers are great.
I quit.
I can't say damn bad thing.
Every single one of the fellows is like inspirational,
amazing,
doing great work.
The thing is though,
something gets so good and people feel the power that they have and then they
impose rules and that's how society got created in the beginning.
Somebody got so liked and got so much power that they could force you to do
things that were entirely unnatural than inhuman.
That's so ridiculous too.
To think that a guy like you who's as busy as you could give up that time and be
angry if you vary from their schedule at all,
that that sounds like it's more to,
I think Ted's a racist [inaudible] kind of crazy too.
Cause other people missed and they kind of picked on me for it.
But even before I got out here I was like,
Yo,
my birthday is Friday.
You want me to stay till Saturday?
Can I at least have my girls stay with me?
Like,
and I'll just use the room like,
oh we can't because you have a roommate at tet,
so you're like 30 40 year old people staying with a roommate.
I was like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Wait.
They make you room with people?
Wait a minute,
how can they do that?
They won't tell you who to sleep with.
They were,
yes.
And they were like,
you have to room.
It's part of the Ted experience.
And I was like,
this is a court at this point you have crossed the threshold.
You're now fucking Scientology.
Yes.
That's crazy.
So they assign you,
they say,
you know what,
we think that Eddie would grow if he lived with Sasha for a week.
Yeah.
So some crazy fuck.
Who's a Sasha Shogun,
who's in there cooking up crystal meth and whatever the fuck he's doing.
He,
you would have to stay with that guy.
Yes.
I mean luckily they put me with this dude software who is amazing.
Cool cat.
I was calling software.
Yeah,
you were really to be able to pull the name of the dude is amazing.
His name was software and I stayed with him,
but I was like,
I'm 30 I haven't stayed in a hotel with people in a minute.
You know how big is the hotel?
It's a small shitty hotel.
It's the highest reasons he looks like a fucking airport hotel in La.
So you bought,
you're like in the bed next to this guy,
so you got to hear each other snore.
Oh fuck.
What the fuck is that?
And they also hold this shit at long beach and it's like next to like across the
street,
literally you have back to back outback pf Chang's and like subway.
It's ridiculous,
but the whole thing is just weird.
I was like,
I'll pay for my own room.
And they're like,
no,
you're not allowed.
I was like,
you're not allowed to pay for your own room.
Yeah,
they're crazy.
They just want to control you.
That is amazing.
So I still love the talks.
I love all the speakers,
but the organization is fucked.
That's hilarious that they think that they can have that kind of influence over
you.
That's part of the Ted experience.
Eddie is part of the Ted experience.
It's part of the Ted Experience to get Paul that no one's talked about this
before because this seems like straight up boy scouts.
You know what is the thing is most people,
they need 10 they need Ted to put you on.
They want the co sign.
And most people,
it's like,
if you do something for me,
I won't say anything about you.
But that's,
I mean,
I think Joe,
you're the same way.
I don't give a fuck what you do for me.
If you're a fucking Weirdo and you're about to start some new Colt conference
religion,
I'm going to say something.
Right.
I'm not going to follow your rules.
I would write a book about this if I try.
They actually tried to get me to do what they wanted me to do for four,
five,
six,
seven days,
whatever it was and not paying you.
They send packets to to be like this is how to network with billionaires.
Wow.
Like how to go to a network with billionaires,
how to go to a network and talk to people and like talk to potential people who
could collaborate and work with you.
They're like,
don't just go ask them for money.
And I'm like,
this is crazy.
Oh my God.
Just go ask them for money and it's in the packets and you're a grown ass man
and they pick you like you're obviously intelligent if you're getting picked for
10 and they're like today when it rains you should pack a punch.
It's wild.
I see.
That holds.
That is harder.
Okay.
What that is is exactly the opposite of the vehicle that got them there and the
vehicle that got them there is the Internet.
What got them there is the fact that the freedom of the Internet allows people
to exchange interesting conversations like that.
Hey,
you got to listen to this.
You got to wash us.
This lady gave the speech on monkeys.
It was amazing.
Whatever you and what they did is the exact opposite of that.
And that's why even though Obama was focusing on gun control,
the most important debate that Americans will face in the next five years is
internet freedom.
Internet freedom is the most important debate we will face.
And we heard so fucking blind to it because the lobbyists are doing it under
like under our noses.
Yeah,
you,
you surely should have the right and ability to put your own website up and
control your own content and express yourself any in any way shape,
form you choose.
And the benefits of that have been staggering to our culture over the last
couple of years,
just over the last 10 you know,
and the idea that corporations might have the ability to step in and stop that
or regulate that or restrict that or sensor you if in anything that you do and
somehow or another if anything you do in somehow or another one way or a forms
cost them money and they decide that this is something that has to be stopped,
they're going to be able to do that unless we do something and once somebody
realizes that they have their hand on the faucet and they have the ability to
turn it on and turn it off,
people get crazy.
You've seen that study guide like these 10 people,
they even BlocPower yeah,
they do this shit where they invite these people to go talk and they actually
don't put up everybody's talks until this year.
They used to pick and choose and cherry pick the talks they'd put up and you
would go there for a week,
15 hours a day,
do all their shit,
and then imagine if they didn't put up your talk,
but what have you talk socks.
If you're talk sucked,
I feel like it should just go suck on the Internet.
Like it'll go hide in a corner on the Internet.
Right.
But maybe yes and no,
because if you like,
say if you had a comedy conference and uh,
you had all these comedians do sets,
but some of them were just dog shit.
You want that set to represent your,
your company.
No,
you would,
you know,
you wouldn't do it.
Yeah,
I wouldn't,
you know,
if I did though,
invite someone and they stayed for a week and I didn't pay them,
I would be like,
the least I owe you is the opportunity that quite possibly there's three people
on the planet at that enjoy your stuff.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's one point.
That's a point.
I guess.
Again,
I know what you're saying to protect the brand.
It makes a little sense,
but you know,
for the most part,
most people's talks are fucking good.
Yeah.
They're there for a reason.
So it's probably really different.
They're not going to get an open miker Ted talker.
Yeah,
but it's not a bringer show.
Right.
But they give opportunities to a lot of weird people mean it's absolutely
possible.
There must be,
I bet if we just ask,
I bet we're ignorant to it.
But we just say,
show me the Ted talks,
that sucker fat Dick,
they're going to,
it's okay.
Twitter,
Twitter people please show me the Ted talks that soccer fat Dick,
everyone wants to see the Sarah Silverman,
ted talk.
There was never let out.
She got us.
She gave us,
they never let it out cause she made fun of Ted.
See I would have fucking wanted to watch that to meet your weekly and the thing
is if your confidence that you're allow you,
you can laugh at yourself.
They don't know how to laugh at themselves.
She made fun of Ted.
In what way?
Like during her talk,
it's like the mythology of it.
I didn't see the talk obviously,
but how was the Sarah Silverman,
Ted Talk?
They never let out.
Wow.
We need to get serious.
I need to run into her somewhere.
I could,
I couldn't make it happen.
Okay.
Am I going to happen hurt?
Um,
I,
uh,
I've never heard anything bad about ted before,
so that's why this is such a shock.
It is weird though.
You meet the donors and stuff and they can't tell Asian people apart.
They can't tell African people apart and it's just,
it's weird man.
Like they're nice and everybody means well.
Did they call you David Cho?
No.
They just mistake you for other fellows because so many of them are Asian.
Really?
That's funny.
Yeah.
How many different people do it every year?
Uh,
every year they pick like 20 fellows and then they pick a bunch of other people
for the main stage.
So yeah.
I mean,
no,
it is,
it is a ill organization.
I still,
even though they booted me today,
I,
I love the speakers.
I love the talks and I want it to continue,
but I hope that they,
at least,
you know,
they can say I suck and that's fine.
They can be like,
Eddie's a shithead.
He went to la,
he did the fucking podcast and he sucks,
but I hope they just changed the rules for future people.
So you didn't do anything wrong.
They're crazy and all they represent is a distribution method for the greatest
minds on earth.
That's all they represent.
It's not that they are the greatest minds on earth,
it's just there's so many interesting people today.
We live in an amazing time.
And just when you good,
something like Ted,
whatever the Ted stands for,
it became synonymous on the Internet with fascinating talks.
Yeah,
boom.
And then it's off.
But if you want you could do to Eddie Wong's,
you know,
fascinating motherfuckers on vice and do the exact same thing.
I think there's a lot of room for that.
Cause conferences like I would love to hear more people from,
you know,
downtown La,
downtown New York and talking and doing these ideas because they don't find
those dudes.
They find academics,
they find people playing ancient instruments.
They find people that are,
you know,
working nature things and they have their kind of like cultural sect,
you know.
But there is a lot of room to find genius in other places,
geniuses everywhere.
You know this,
you travel around the world,
you find genius anywhere.
So there's room for conferences that like look under different cultures cause
they're kind of looking under the same stones all the time.
Right.
And they're going to run out of bugs.
Yeah.
And I'm one of the,
I'm one of the first time they've stepped out to be like,
all right,
there's this dude,
he's Chinese,
he's into hip hop.
He lives in downtown New York.
He used to sell drugs.
He now has a restaurant.
Um,
I think I was the only working chef that was a ted fellow.
So I,
I was one of their choices that was really out there,
but it just didn't work out but didn't work out because you're not willing to be
a fucking slave and sleep in a hotel room with a stranger for a week.
Yeah.
That's insane.
They had me.
I rehearsed for two days.
I fucking did the tour.
I did everything I'm supposed to do,
and then I was like,
I'm going to just piece out for like a half day and they bugged.
Wow.
You know you.
That's,
that's crazy.
And it's fact that they don't pay you.
It's crazy.
You guys need to do a vice show.
Exposing Ted how?
Loony tabs.
I told vice that I told,
I said before I got booted,
I sent them an email like,
Yo,
you got to see this shit.
It's like the beginnings of Scientology.
Wow.
It is so true that once people have a position of power and influence and people
want to be a part of them,
people go corrupt.
Yup.
What is the threshold at which something becomes a religion?
You know,
it's kind of insane.
It's so easy to start a cult today.
Yeah.
There's so many people looking at jump on board.
You know?
All the people that would have a hundred years ago become Catholics now.
They're like,
man,
I just won't stop fucking kids.
I can't do this.
I needed a new cult.
I don't know why.
People still believe in these.
Really like you look at what these people are doing.
Like what these,
what's happening in the Catholic church.
It's insane.
Fucking popes resigning.
Cause the first time it's gotten so hot that the pope's like I'm Outta here.
He's asked for immunity from the Catholic,
from the,
uh,
Italian government,
from prosecution because he's responsible for shielding pedophiles.
He personally,
and a lot of people don't know this,
the pope personally responsible for taking pedophiles and shifting them away to
another place where they molested markets.
And what would you expect?
You don't,
these people aren't allowed to have sex.
It's natural to want to have sex.
It's natural to want to go to La and do podcasts.
You know,
soon you cannot come to Ted and have sex without condoms.
I'd be like,
fuck that.
You could imagine no unprotected sex.
No raw dogging.
Attend illegal.
No Ass fucking while you're here.
Oh Man.
Ted Fellow.
There'll be a mutiny.
I wonder if they would have like you,
you could slowly start imposing behavior standards,
you know,
on fellows,
if you want to call it like a ted fellow or,
or whatever new organization you want to start,
they do shit.
Like you should have a standing,
you should give a standing ovation when this person comes,
you should do this and that.
It's easy.
It's all,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Fake standing ovations.
Yeah.
And they were also saying like,
you know,
when the founder comes,
Chris Anderson comes like,
you don't have to give him a standing ovation.
Like,
you know,
it's nice if you want to,
but he doesn't actually need you to do it.
I'm like,
the fact that you needed to give me this fake halfway disclaimer is so fucking
strange.
Wow.
That's so strange.
Yeah.
They tell you who to and not to give standing ovations to who's allowed to
apply.
You have to apply to go to Ted to attend.
And then once you're accepted,
you pay $8,000.
Well,
that's a mind fuck.
Wait a minute.
You had to pay.
No.
Hell No.
I did.
But the people who do it,
they applied.
Okay.
So the people that attend these strict audience members,
you're saying you got to want to be so down so bad to do that,
to go through an application process and then fucking pay.
That's a lot of money.
How many people are going now?
Maybe we'll go.
I don't know.
I think,
uh,
like 2000,
3000.
Whoa.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
That's a lot of money.
They make holy shit.
Yeah.
That's a lot of money.
They make off it.
Yeah.
2000 people paying $8,000 is how much?
Uh,
six,
300.
60,000?
No,
1600.
What is it?
160,000?
No.
Oh,
is that we're going to be more,
no,
it's way more than that.
It's like 16 million I think,
but yeah,
2000,
2000 and 16 million.
2000 Times.
You don't know shit about your numbers and I didn't even bother counting gay
Asian always.
I'm asking agents from now on January 16 million in Miami.
You silly bitch.
What is it,
Brian?
Do you,
do you ever calculate a builtin?
What's the number?
What's number 2000 times 8,000 got gotta be 16 million.
What's 2000 times 8,000
this might answer your question.
Uh,
it is 1.6 million I think.
Oh,
1.6 million.
That was one off.
I was excited.
Okay.
That makes a lot of bread.
So they made 1.6 million.
16 million.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right,
so human calculator was fast.
Very nice.
So,
um,
they made 16 million,
which is even crazier.
And they did this in this time where you were there and no one got paid.
Paid.
Nobody got paid.
Wow.
Yup.
We are suckers,
dude.
Why suckers?
And they're always telling you like you're going to get exposure.
It was like no lie.
More people listen to the Joe Rogan experience.
That's true.
Ted.
Suck it.
Yeah.
Ted,
we got you beat by like a million.
Yup.
But that's still nuts,
man.
That's a lot of money.
We're not making that money.
We need to make that money.
We got to get 80,000 people.
Joe Rogan had $1 million each.
I know how to do it.
All right.
I'm going to just raise the bar and only get really stupid rich people.